salmonella enterica is one of the
pathogen which is a lead cause of
enteric disease and it caused
salmonellosis
salmonellosis is characterized by
diarrhea abdominal pain cramp and fever
it is a gram-negative bacteria
facultative anaerobe that does not form
Spore and the mode of transmission is
generally fecal to oral root also there
could be transmission from contaminated
water or food unpasteurized milk raw
meat or even contact with poultry animal
is sufficient to cause the infection
enteric fever is characterized by high
fever nausea abdominal pain and also
maculopopular rash is kind of visible
treatment involves antibiotics as it's a
bacterial infection like ciprofloxacin
azithromycin also oral rehydration and
IV injections could be useful watch the
full video for more